it was a historical moment on an  historic day yesterday amanda gorman who  you see behind me  she became the youngest known poet at a  presidential inauguration  the 23 year old delivered her original  composition the hill we  climb gorman spoke with cbs this morning  and said that she learned about the  inauguration performance back in  december  i was sitting on it for a really long  time even kind of nervous about telling  my mom because i knew she would want to  shout it from the rooftops because it  was just  such an amazing opportunity gorman says  she researched the speeches of abraham  lincoln and dr martin luther king jr as  she began writing yesterday's poem  and she came up with something pretty  remarkable meanwhile clark county is  looking for its own  new poet it is seeking nominations and  candidates to be the county's poet  laureate  to get the position you have to live in  clark county obviously and be available  for public  appearances